Everyone knows what a Jedi is — but who's
in charge of the Jedi Order?
And what happens to trainees who don't pass
their tests?
If you're wondering about the hierarchy of
the galaxy's guardians of justice and peace,
here's your guide.
The lowest rank in the Jedi hierarchy are
Jedi Younglings, also known as initiates.
According to the book Jedi vs. Sith: The Essential
Guide to the Force, younglings are children
sensitive to the Force who were gathered from
across the galaxy as infants to be trained
as future Jedi.
The Jedi Path: A Manual for Students of the
Force explains that at one time, young adults
and adolescents were recruited as Jedi Younglings,
but the Order found that these older recruits
were already exposed to negative emotions
that could push them to the dark side.
As a result, the Jedi began recruiting children
who were younger, and more innocent.
Younglings don't train with mentors one-on-one.
Instead, they're separated into small groups
called clans, and train together within those
clans.
Once younglings learn their basics, they must
take a series of tests known as the Initiate
Trials, which have included such tasks as
building a lightsaber.
Though the Initiate Trials have changed over
time, their ultimate goal is to determine
students' knowledge of the Jedi Code and ability
to conquer the Dark Side.
Unlike the group training for younglings,
Padawans receive one-on-one coaching in real-life
missions — a significant hurdle for most
Padawans to clear.
"Oh, it's you!"
Similar to younglings, Padawans must also
pass a series of trials to move up in rank.
These tests include the Trial of Skill, the
Trial of Courage, the Trial of Flesh, the
Trial of Spirit, and the Trial of Insight.
The Trials test a Padawan's mental and physical
abilities and determine if they are ready
to become a full-fledged Jedi.
"The Force is with you, young Skywalker.
But you are not a Jedi yet."
Not every Padawan graduates to the rank of
Jedi Knight.
But unsuccessful initiates can still become
members of the Jedi Service Corps.
This organization is separated into four arms:
Agricultural, Medical, Educational, and Exploration.
The Agricultural Corps use the Force to help
ensure that the Republic has enough food to
go around.
The Medical Corps is considered one of the
most advanced medical organizations in the
Republic, with its members performing specialized
procedures and triage work on battlefields
across the galaxy.
The Educational Corps work with the Jedi archives,
translating and updating records.
The most exciting branch is arguably the Exploration
Corps, whose members are sent to the far-flung
corners of space to make new discoveries.
Jedi Knights are fully-fledged members of
the Order, expected to uphold peace in the
galaxy and the ideals of the Jedi Code.
The most common way to become a Jedi Knight
is by passing trials as a Padawan, but an
individual can also be granted the title by
performing a heroic deed, like Obi-Wan Kenobi
assuming the rank after defeating Darth Maul.
At this point in the hierarchy, Jedi Knights
still have much to learn about the Force,
but they no longer carry out their duties
under the direct supervision of a Jedi Master.
Most Jedi Knights carry out their missions
alone, testing their self-discipline and upholding
the principles of the Jedi Code.
When people think of the Jedi, two things
usually come to mind: the Force and lightsabers.
"Who are the Jedi?"
In many cases, those who specialize in the
manipulation of the Force pursue the title
of Jedi Consular.
Most of these Jedi are focused on using their
connection to the Force to resolve conflicts
in a peaceful way.
The most esteemed Jedi Consular Masters serve
on the Reconciliation Council, a select group
of Jedi who work directly with the Republic
Diplomatic Corps to engage in diplomacy and
interplanetary relations.
There are many different ways for Jedi Consulars
to use their talents within the Order.
Jedi Seers use deep meditation to connect
to the Force and receive visions of the past,
present, and future.
For instance, the prophecy of the one who
will bring balance to the Force was the product
of visions received by Jedi Seers who recorded
their findings in the Jedi Archives.
Other Consulars become Jedi Healers, who use
their connection to the Force to mend broken
bodies.
Others work as Jedi Ambassadors and Jedi Diplomats,
serving as representatives in various government
bodies and activist movements respectively.
Other Consulars might become Jedi Lorekeepers,
dedicated to maintaining to the Jedi Archives.
In the years leading up to the Clone Wars,
the Republic had no standing army.
Instead, specialized Jedi Knights known as
Guardians acted as the first line of defense
for the galaxy.
Guardians are divided into three main subclasses:
Peacekeepers, Temple Security, and Starfighters.
Peacekeepers act as galactic police, trained
in crowd control and deescalation of threats.
Jedi assigned to Temple Security protect the
Jedi Temple on the planet Coruscant.
As their name implies, Starfighters serve
as the pilots of the Jedi Order.
Particularly gifted Jedi Guardians may be
known as Battlemasters, tasked with teaching
lightsaber form and techniques, or cadences,
to Jedi in training.
Some Guardians come to specialize in fighting
with weapons other than a lightsaber, being
awarded the title of Exotic Weapons Specialist.
These weapons can include whips, flails, blasters,
and even double-bladed lightsabers.
Jedi Sentinels are like the Order's wild cards.
Sentinels pursue training in disciplines that
are also available to non-force sensitive
beings.
In doing so, they add modern insight and skills
to the the Jedi Order's ancient teachings.
Common pursuits for Jedi Sentinels include
specializing in computer systems, manipulation
of technology, and hacking into and disabling
security mechanisms.
Other Sentinels do exceedingly well on missions
that require stealth and infiltration.
One particular group of Sentinels known as
the Jedi Shadows serve as the Order's assassins
and excel at sneaky, less combat-oriented
tasks.
Jedi Sentinels are also distinguished by often
remaining in one area for much longer than
other Jedi, acting as Watchmen for particular
regions of the galaxy.
If a Jedi has shown exemplary skill, deep
knowledge of the Force, and successfully trained
an apprentice to become a Jedi Knight, they
may be granted the title of Jedi Master.
"Don't f--- with a Jedi Master, son."
A Master's purpose is to be a positive force
in the galaxy, and to expand the influence
of the Jedi Order.
What separates a Jedi Master from a Jedi Knight
is that their exceptional achievements and
experience make them uniquely qualified to
teach the younger members of the Order.
In addition to teaching younger Jedi, they
are also naturally fit to lead the Order,
not just by example, but by sitting on one
of the four Jedi Councils that govern the
Order.
The four councils are known as the Council
of First Knowledge, the Council of Reconciliation,
the Council of Reassignment, and the High
Council.
The Council of First Knowledge oversees the
education of younger Jedi and the dissemination
of materials from the Jedi Archives.
This council is usually comprised of Consulars
who became Lorekeepers.
The Council of Reconciliation, meanwhile,
deals in politics and diplomacy.
This council is also regularly filled with
Consulars, as well as Diplomats and Ambassadors.
The Council of Reassignment governs the Jedi
Service Corps, dictating which body each initiate
will be funneled into after they fail to advance
on the path to Jedi Knighthood.
These councils are all governed by the High
Council.
During the Clone Wars, the High Council was
made up of five lifetime appointees, four
long-term appointees, and three short-term
appointees, making for a total of 12 council
members.
The High Council oversees everything within
the Order and is crucial to its stability
and success.
The highest ranking member within the High
Council is given the title Master of the Order.
This prestigious position is only obtained
by those who have demonstrated incredible
knowledge of the ways of the Jedi.
In the years leading up to the Clone Wars,
the title of Master of the Order was held
by Lifetime Appointee Mace Windu.
After the Clone Wars began, Master Windu decided
to take a more active role in commanding troops
on the battlefield, and insisted that the
title be passed to Master Yoda.
Though Master of the Order is a prestigious
position, they are still outranked by one
final position: the Grand Master.
The Grand Master is the most prestigious rank
in the Jedi hierarchy, awarded to only the
wisest and most skilled.
The Jedi High Council must unanimously vote
to bestow the title onto them.
Grand Masters often serve in conjunction with
the Master of the Order, leading the Jedi
High Council.
While at one time several Jedi Masters could
be given the title at once, that practice
ended long before the time of the Clone Wars.
One of the most critical roles held by the
Grand Master is to pass on their knowledge
to the next generation of Jedi.
Part of this duty involves training younglings
in the ways of the Force.
Two notable figures have achieved the title
of Grand Master.
During the Clone Wars, Master Yoda was recognized
as the Grand Master of the Jedi Order.
Afterward, at least in the old Expanded Universe
books, Luke Skywalker invokes the title of
Grand Master as he rebuilds the Jedi Order
following the fall of the Empire.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.